so we got some crazy news this morning
apparently Ukraine sent a drone to kill
Vladimir Putin fortunately he was not
there he did not die except that's the
narrative coming out of the Kremlin we
don't actually know what really happened
there is the fog of war and many people
are saying either this was a false flag
attack on the Kremlin so that there
would be some kind of justification for
escalation or an attempt to Rally public
support in Russia for the war in Ukraine
or Ukraine actually did make a crude
attempt at taking out Vladimir Putin
either way you can expect some kind of
escalation and there are many people who
are saying oh no this is it this is
World War III and I'm kind of like I
don't know if this is it but an attack
on the Kremlin is fairly serious and if
it wasn't really an attack on the
Kremlin they're going to act like it was
so still fairly serious but we'll talk
about that we got some news as it
pertains to Anheuser-Busch apparently
they've begun giving out free Bud Light
to distributors in desperation wow I did
not think the boycott would be so
effective they'd start giving the beer
away desperately because nobody's buying
it but this is where we are right now
and then um I guess because you know I'm
trying to give you a a black pill
sandwich it's like we got really bad
news on war and there's some good news
you know boy guys we're gonna hear some
bad news again more banks are collapsing
so uh you know how you doing I hope you
guys have taken precautions and
consulted with a fine financial advisor
as First Republic Bank was seized by the
US government sold out to JP Morgan and
now more banks are starting to fall
we'll see how this one plays out before
we get started my friends today's
episode is brought to you by Public
Square we are huge fans of Public Square
go to publicsq.com download the app this
is an app that shows you businesses who
actually share American values stop
giving money to companies that hate you
give your money to companies that
believe in what you believe in and if
you're trying to find these businesses
it's simple go to publicsq.com sign up
download the app look at the map and you
can see all of the businesses in your
area yeah and even around the country
and digital businesses with online
shipping and shopping that agree with
your values it's really incredible we've
had them on this show before and uh the
the founders were really big fans of
what Public Square is doing especially
when we're talking about these boycotts
with Anheuser-Busch and things like that
the easiest way for you to win is to
vote with your dollars again shout out
to our good friends over at Public
Square we are really big fans
publicesq.com
thanks for sponsoring the show guys and
head over to timcast.com click that join
us button to become a member join the
Discord server to talk with like-minded
individuals 24 7. share your thoughts
and ideas and even submit questions to
call into our members only uncensored
show Monday through Thursday at about 10
10 p.m Eastern we put the show up on the
front page of the website live and of
course archived and we're gonna have one
of these shows tonight it's going to be
a whole lot of fun so support our work
directly by becoming a member and you
can check out that uncensored show smash
the like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
joining us tonight to talk about all of
this and more is James Rosen thank you
who are you sir oh identify yourself yes
yes I have my ID somewhere here uh James
Rosen chief White House correspondent
for Newsmax and author most recently of
Scalia rise to Greatness 1936 to 1986
volume 1 of a two-volume biography of
Antonin Scalia is there a website URL or
something for people to find the book uh
you can just go to my Twitter feed at
James Rosen TV you'll find everything
you need there and I think
um I don't know what what I most have
known you for is because 10 years ago
you were illegally and I I'm assuming
literally and codified as illegal or
adjudicated as I go but in our view and
all the activists spied on and targeted
by the Obama Administration for
literally doing journalism and it was
shockingly corrupt so this story was was
huge in the activist circles and the
Freedom of Information circles strangely
now many of these left-winning
individuals have abandoned those
principles but but that was you targeted
by Obama so yeah this we're actually
coming up on the 10th anniversary three
of when this all first came to light it
was May 20 2013.
um but it but the actual surveillance
that you're talking about had happened
earlier
um how does how to how to make this
brief I I was a reporter for Fox News at
the time I was covering the state
department and I did a series of reports
relating to different facets of North
Korea their nuclear program how they
intended to respond to various actions
by the United States vis-a-vis their
nuclear program and also information
relating to the succession plan that
resulted in Kim Jong-un taking power in
North Korea and that reporting at the
time for Fox News even
was able to to expose the fact that uh
the uh the mission of North Korea at the
United Nations in New York was sending
out points sort of talking points about
the sun Kim Jong-un who was only family
known at that time that were to be
absorbed and internalized by all North
Korean Personnel diplomatic Personnel
around the world
eventually the Obama Administration
concerned about my reporting launched a
national security leak investigation and
they zeroed in on someone whom they
identified as a source for me
and ultimately to avoid the the the
lengthy and debilitating costs of a
trial that person stood up in open court
and pleaded guilty to providing National
Defense information to James Rosen of
Fox News I have never identified whether
this person was a source of mine or not
because I don't think that's an
appropriate business for reporters but
they called you a co-conspirator yes and
so as it was it was later disclosed that
in order to have access to all of my
gmails uh with which which I used to
communicate with sources and to the
phone records pertaining to 20 different
phone lines associated with me including
even the phone records of my parents on
Staten Island at the time wow an FBI
agent swore out a sworn statement an
affidavit for a search warrant
application for a federal judge to
approve and in that document this FBI
agent attested that
given his experience James Rosen is
running his sources like an intelligence
officer which was almost like a a
professional complement of sorts but
they uh they designated me in that
document as a criminal co-conspirator in
a violation of the Espionage Act and it
was the first time that's ever been
applied to any reporter let's just by
way of context Neil Sheehan now deceased
who was the New York Times Reporter who
in 1971 broke the Pentagon papers which
was seven thousand pages of classified
documents an internal defense department
study tracing the Arc of American
involvement in Vietnam not even the
Nixon Administration designated Neil
Sheehan as a criminal co-conspirator in
a violation of the Espionage Act how did
this resolve itself President Obama
himself himself at a speech at National
Defense University on counter-terrorism
at the time proclaimed himself troubled
by the notion
of working reporters being criminalized
for doing their jobs
and uh to get to the bottom of how this
possibly could have happened this novel
legal designation that was applied in a
secret search warrant application filed
by an FBI officer and approved by a
federal judge so they could gain access
to all of those records to get to the
bottom of how that happened
President Obama in what passed for
accountability at the time appointed to
investigate the whole thing well the
person who had actually approved the
search warrant and that novel
designation which was Attorney General
Eric Holder wow I'll tell you quickly
another facet to this story The The
Washington Post broke the story on May
20 2013 that the FBI and the state
department had been spying on James
Rosen of Fox News
including monitoring my my uh my
whereabouts
examining where and when I I used my
swipe badge at the state department all
the phone records that we've talked
about the gmails that was May 20 of
2013. as it happened attorney general
holder who quickly acknowledged that he
was responsible for this extraordinary
legal step that the United States
government had never taken before
designating a working reporter as a
criminal co-conspirator for doing his
job five days earlier on May 15 of 2013
attorney general holder was testifying
before the house Judiciary Committee and
he was asked about the potential
prosecution of a member of the news
media for the unauthorized disclosure of
classified information and I'm
paraphrasing but pretty closely he said
in terms of the potential prosecution of
a member of the news media for the
unauthorized disclosure of classified
information which is something that goes
on by the way every day in Washington
Bob Woodward is famous for having walked
off the White House grounds with
classified Maps they're doing to Trump
right now all day every day okay lots of
classified information gets published
but holder said in terms of the
potential prosecution of a member of the
news media for the unauthorized
disclosure of classified information
that's not something I've ever heard of
been involved in or would think would be
wise policy and five days later the post
broke the story of what was done to me
so you're saying they're Liars so I'm
telling you that the majority staff of
the house Judiciary Committee at the
time which was Republican later issued a
a formal report
concluding that attorney general
holder's testimony on that occasion had
been false and misleading
shock of shocks the DC bar did not rise
up to immediately begin investigating
whether the Attorney General should keep
his law license he was asked by Jonathan
K part of MSNBC towards the end of his
tenure what his biggest regret from his
time as attorney general was and he said
oh the thing involving um what's his
name the fox reporter Rosen you know
with this studied sort of nonchalance
that was one episode well
I think that breaks down who you are
yeah sure there's more well we'll get
into all that we also uh know Sheamus
tonight we have Hannah Claire Grandma
hanging out hi I'm Hannah brimlow I'm a
writer for timcast.com I'm really
looking forward to tonight me too
because I'm back yeah you are back
what's happening we have the same hair
someone asked if I was Ian Crossland
with straight hair did you tell them no
of course not I think you'd take care of
your hair more than he does man I was
just in Texas I did Alex steinshaws on
Sarah Gonzalez at the blaze if you guys
didn't see it you're going to want to
check it out Alex Stein is a wild wild
man and it gave me a new lease on life A
New Perspective realizing that you know
Twitter isn't everything and that maybe
your family is more important than the
TV but uh and anyway you were talking
about music before the show too talking
about the Beatles James Rosen the most
dedicated Beatles fan on Earth I didn't
know that's right 20 minutes ago
maybe we'll just talk about the Beatles
maybe maybe we'll sing a little song
Ian's back to see you Tim and thanks for
that coffee yesterday it was delicious
yeah the uh Roberto Jr oh my gosh got a
Nutty Nutty yeah it's bright it's a
light Rose
tomorrow I'm very much enjoying we also
have to my right Serge duprea hey guys
uh yeah let's get started all right so
here's the uh oh what was that here's
the first story we got from The
Washington Post Ukraine denies kremlin's
claim of drone assassination attempt on
Putin now we have this video that was uh
posted by the times on YouTube I'm gonna
play the clip for you I don't think
there's any audio and uh you just see a
uh weird little object fly in and then
blow up
and that's it
so it exploded over the building and uh
I guess what happened was they they
destroyed it before I mean you're not
gonna get a drone into the Kremlin I
mean they've got air defenses according
to Washington Post they say Russia on
Wednesday accused Ukraine of staging a
drone attack intending intended to kill
Vladimir Putin in the Kremlin
an incendiary allegation that was
forcefully denied by Ukrainian officials
some of whom warned it could be a
pretext for Russia to escalate the war
it is it absolutely is whether or not
it's a false flag whether or not Ukraine
actually did it there's video they
claimed it happened and that's what
you're going to see some kind of
escalation some kind of justification
perhaps it's Vladimir Putin trying to
Rally public support in his country to
for the ongoing war or because he wants
to turn the heat up and use more
advanced weapons or something like that
and he needs some kind of justification
or maybe Ukraine just try to do it maybe
maybe it could be an Insurgent faction
it could be a group of Ukraine who knows
but I wouldn't put it past them I do
kind of think this was crude and poorly
done so it's probably I don't know I'd
assume more was a false flag yeah first
I heard there were two drones and that
they were brought down by Russian uh
like countermeasures and so that was the
Drone actually coming down as a result
of the Russian interference so that but
I don't know if that was true or not
either I mean
they released a statement saying it was
too unmanned aerial uh two drones
apparatuses and they also said you know
we have uh May 9th which is our Victory
Day we we celebrate the end or when
Germany fell to the Soviet Union and so
this is lining up on sort of to be an
attack on our our national pride
basically this is this is basically the
White House that's like the Russian
version of The White House Washington
Post says it's the working residence of
Vladimir Putin but to fly a drone I mean
the explosion was very small compared to
the building just to aim a thing into
the top of the Kremlin I don't see how
that would get put maybe they knew where
they were headed and they were trying to
go right into his office
he wasn't even there what kind of drone
was it is the question was it a small
you know commercial consumer drone or
something or was it you know an American
military style Reaper or whatever it was
a loaded with explosives or was that
just the machine itself being blown
apart yo I warned about this 10 years
ago this is crazy to see happen I was uh
I was doing research in 2011 on drone
stuff and when I it was about 2014 I
think I actually went to the um what is
it the Northwestern drone Coalition a
group of uh universities were working
with the government and news
organizations to figure out what are we
doing about this new technology and when
I went and met with these University
people I outright told them your biggest
concern is probably security because
someone's going to take one of these
things they're going to arm it and
they're going to fly it straight into a
city and there is nothing you can do at
that point at that point your question
is where does it blow up not if it will
and swarm technology is the next level
right now now we're seeing in in Ukraine
these small commercial style drones and
military ones but that are small
carrying explosives and payloads
swarming and just peppering targets and
stuff like that you'll need like a laser
defense system where like there's a
pylon that if there's like 10 000 drones
all coming that the thing will like
spark out 10 000 shocks and hit them all
at once and knock them all down I don't
think you can't stop them individually
it's not going to be able to move fast
enough if they did some kind of laser
defense system I think that could work
so uh you would need a high-powered
laser but it's not going to be well it
could theoretically move fast enough but
to transfer enough energy from the from
the laser to the Drone to disable it
might take more than than just a second
you would need huge amounts of energy
for that it would it would point at it
hold for about a second and probably
take it out of the sky instantly
scramble it up heat it up overheat it
but if there's 10 000 of these drones or
even a few hundred of them this laser is
not going to be able to stop all of them
what vibe did you get James about this
whole thing there's so much that we
don't know and our primary source of
information about it we have to remember
is the Kremlin right so even the video
itself it's intriguing to me that we're
being allowed to see it why would
um the Russians release video of what
they're claiming was a almost a
successful attack on the Kremlin right
benefits them well maybe
um
so be that as it may first our only
source of information is a very
unreliable one okay
um as to the question of whether this
could be the pretext for an escalation
whether it was a false flag or a genuine
Ukrainian attack the Russians haven't
shown throughout this entire conflict
that they need any particular pretext to
escalate the whole the war itself is an
enormous escalation right there was no
conflict so I don't think they
particularly need any any staged events
or even a real event to claim as a
justification for for escalation and the
fact is too that the the Russian
military throughout this conflict has
been so shockingly
ineffective that I'm not sure that what
what escalations they can even
successfully Mount beyond the obvious
one that we all worry about which is the
introduction of some kind of nuclear
conventional or tactical convention or
or or
Genuine nuke size nuclear escalation I
don't think they're going to go there
and so
um uh the one thing I would say about
this is it brings up this this posture
of the United States throughout this
conflict which is that we are not
encouraging or enabling
the Ukrainian Armed Forces to launch
attacks inside Crimea or Russia itself
and the question is why not wouldn't the
war be over much more swiftly if
Vladimir Putin and the ruling class in
Russia were made to pay those kinds of
prices the very prices the ukrainians
themselves are paying they want to avoid
Total War they're seeking a limited war
in eastern Ukraine they don't want Putin
to get killed they don't want zelinsky
to get killed because then it's Joe
Biden's on the line so I think this is I
honestly think this is a way for the
Russians to establish grievances in the
global community and be like see now we
have a little bit of justification if we
do decide to go after zielinski so
zelinski you better run and he's like in
Finland right now or something and he
decided to stay I think he's uh he's up
in Nordic country I just want to say if
this really was a false flag it is the
saddest and most pathetic we've seen I
mean you've got the the burning of the
reichstag which many people believe was
a false flag to justify expansion of war
and things like that and that was
literally burning the whole thing to the
ground this is is like a little
explosion overhead that didn't do much
damage at all and Putin wasn't even
there so I'm not I'm not sure what they
get out of this really and so some
people I already seen the Super Chat are
pointing out that there's no way those
drones flew 400 500 kilometers to make
it there so what what is this it's like
high altitude reconnaissance drones
maybe it just got brought down by some
sort of magnetic we're gonna have to I'm
sorry go ahead there you go
um we're just going to have to acclimate
ourselves to the reality that we're not
going to learn all that we would wish to
learn about this event uh but just to
your point before about uh you know the
reason why the US is just not
encouraging or enabling Ukrainian Armed
Forces to to strike inside Russian
territory is because they fear World War
III but it just seems to me you're
already in a kind of a proxy war to
begin with right
um and
um it's a strange way to pursue War
making uh if you're every decision is
going to be governed by fear of the
opponent escalating the conflict aren't
they enabling isn't the US enabling by
funding this war though I mean we send
materials and supplies to we are the war
so we are saying oh we're not enabling
it but we are well in other words uh I
don't know whether the particular weapon
systems that we've been supplying would
enable uh the Ukrainian Armed Forces to
to do damage inside territorial Russia
um probably there's a suite of weapon
systems we could Supply that would
guarantee the ability of the ukrainians
to uh to to pursue war on Russian
targets but uh it's sort of an ambiguous
line we're saying we're not sure it
could but and radically but but they
don't need to agree with you they don't
need full-scale Warfare weapons from us
to engage in Conflict on Russian
territory in Russian territory in fact
that would probably be the least
effective thing to do the most effective
thing to do is what that lady did when
she brought the statue to that blogger
and blew them up
like Insurgency style targeted guerrilla
warfare disrupting the economy I mean
they're not gonna there's nothing
they're gonna have that's gonna be able
to do enough damage to it to these areas
and if they did open strike on a Russian
city would be a total annihilation of
every Ukrainian major city by the
Russian Air Force it was just overnight
it would just be Total War the entire
country would be level to the ground if
they started attacking Russian cities
this is the crazy thing to me about this
whole thing the the the restraint you
see in war makes no sense like you you
Ukraine could easily have more of these
assassinations with the with the statue
for you you guys know about that story
first heard of it for those that don't
know there was this uh I guess it was it
was a vlog a vlogger he was a guy who
would make you know who propagandize in
favor of Russia and he was given us a
bust of himself and it exploded killing
him and injuring several others these
are the kinds of attacks taking out key
targets that are are easier and more
effective in terms of destabilizing you
know uh and they instill Terror exactly
the populace wants to know well where is
the next place that could be struck and
strictly but but what you were saying
Ian was that if ukrainians did use U.S
granted or NATO weapon Grant granted
weapons of war on a Russian city Russia
would retaliate with full-scale air
strikes my question is why why don't
they do it now because they want to own
the country I don't think that I think
they really want trade out of this they
want to be a richer country after this
war is over them before it started so
they're trying to take Eastern ukrainees
to the dawn bass run those freeways down
to Crimea and just start shipping steel
out into the Mediterranean and I do I do
want to stress there are U.S boots on
the ground that was confirmed in the in
the leaks that came out a while ago plus
there's there's several other European
countries that have boots on the ground
and Hannah Claire's point is is true
which is what distinction are you really
making when
um on the one hand you're saying well we
we are proceeding very carefully up the
S each step up the escalatory ladder so
as not to trigger a you know an
unwelcome escalation from Mr Putin but
you know five minutes later in the same
news conference you're saying our the
the the the weapons and the training
that we're providing are killing Russian
soldiers are causing all these
extraordinary casualties that the
Russians are are absorbing so in essence
you're posting about the very thing that
you're claiming not to be doing but
realistically I think you know
utilitarianly that they care a lot less
about losing humans than they do about
losing infrastructure you blow up
buildings that's going to piss them off
a lot more than killing a bunch of dudes
but again overpopulation at what point
should the should the wet the entire
Western Alliance be governed by fear of
whether uh this particular leader is
going to go nuclear you know does he not
also subscribe to Mad some mutually
assured destruction which govern
relations between the US and the Soviet
Union for 50 years I think that's fake
what's fake mutually assured destruction
in my opinion is uh completely over
hyped and confused by the average person
for some because people tend to simplify
things and because their views are based
off of pop culture and not actual
history they think things like you know
uh gunshots they don't know what they
really sound like they think uh you know
it's it's like the movie Last Action
Hero remember that Schwarzenegger and
Jamie Lee Curtis he shoots the taxi in
the reality he lives in the movie but
then he comes to the real world and he
shoots the car but nothing happens
because in movies shoot a car explodes
like for no reason and so what you have
with mutually shared destruction is this
idea based on intercontinental ballistic
missiles that if Russia were to Nuke a
U.S city we would fire a nuke in return
in retaliation and then the whole world
just blows itself up I don't believe
that's true and I believe that's a myth
and I also believe is it a myth that
there's a second strike capability what
do you mean in other words
if we get nuked we will launch nukes
well in other words what you just
identified as you know
um Preposterous or whatever is the idea
that if we are fired upon with a nuclear
weapon we will fire one back and then
the whole world goes boom isn't it
possible that we clip off the end of
that the whole world going boom and
there's you know do you believe just as
a threshold matter that if we are
attacked with a nuclear weapon we have a
second strike what's called a second
strike capability the ability to launch
the second nuclear strike and retaliate
we so there's so I think there's there's
so much wrong with the presumption first
there's that famous story of the Russian
submarine that received word that a nuke
had been launched and the guy on this
one I guess what do you do he refused to
launch it is the story was that was that
what it was yeah pull that up and guess
the story correct because I I could be
getting it wrong but even when it was
like they have attacked us the nukes are
heading towards us he goes I won't fire
it I won't do it and so that was this
this Legend legendary story or urban
legend whatever you want to call it
historical Legend you know basically he
believed that there was an error because
a lot of Soviet Tech at the time time
was not uh was not as you know are you
sure that he believed it was an error my
understanding was that he refused to
fire even when ordered to I it could be
both but from what I remember that story
that you're talking about who's like on
this I think it was a sub he was on the
sub I believe yeah and he believed that
it was like it was an error it wasn't
the actual it wasn't actually the
beginning of a nuclear war but it was a
movie about this whole subject Fail-Safe
that where the American Pilots have been
given word that we've been attacked and
they they're reluctant to be the ones
that actually you know but that's why
you have command and you know you have a
chain of command and so on but his name
was Vasily uh alexandrovich archipov and
he refused to authorize the captain to
fire nuclear Torpedoes what year was
that
uh wow I'm surprised I'm surprised it's
not there so there there was a um I
think I I think it was a British MP or
someone in Europe said
you would be insane to sacrifice London
or New York for you know uh Warsaw or
something that if if Vladimir Putin were
to use and especially Kiev if Vladimir
Putin were to use intercontinental
ballistic missiles we're talking
multiple independently targeted re-entry
vehicles with 12 Warheads peppering
every major city in Ukraine
I do not believe anyone in the west
would fire upon Russia with nuclear
weapons and if Vladimir Putin were to
actually fire an intercontinental
ballistic missile at Poland I do not
believe the West would launch nuclear
icbms in retaliation at Russia as they
are legally required to to come to their
offense of that required to come to the
defense does not mean firing nukes and
civilian targets so so but why is mad so
so mad is mad is a um is a fallacy or is
a is a popular delusion because well I
think it's more complicated than people
think they think that if Russia were to
launch a nuke then like in that movie
was it war games with Matthew Broderick
all the nukes go flying in the air and I
just don't think that's real reality
because the reality of of uh strategy
and war is not that some dude sitting at
a computer and he's like well a nuke was
fired better fire ours but I will say if
it was World War II if the Japanese had
had nuclear bombs that they probably
would have dropped them back on the
United States after
perhaps but those were gravity bombs the
very first nuclear weapons were dropped
out of bombers and after we knew the
capabilities of the Germans knew the
capabilities of nuclear bombs and there
was a rush to to weaponize this and we
got there first the United States
knowing the capability of a gravity bomb
seeing a bomber with with you know
fighters on its wing they'd be like stop
that bomber and we would definitely be
prepared for something like that but we
shouldn't like allow geography I think
to govern our our Assessments in this
area so that if if it's simply the fact
that uh the United States and Russia are
so far away from each other uh and it
would require intercontinental ballistic
missiles for this kind of exchange to
occur uh let's shrink our example to
India and Pakistan okay which you know
are not as far away from each other and
are both nuclear armed which have a
history of conflict with each other okay
uh do you believe that uh mutually
assured destruction Theory uh obtains in
in that re in that theater we need we
need to break down what it really means
in that there is the reality that if if
Vladimir Putin fired an ICBM a Merv
nuclear-armed nuclear a nuclear-armed
multiple independently targeted re-entry
vehicle with 12 Warheads
it goes up into the air ejects 12
Warheads to Pepper the Eastern Seaboard
of the United States the United States
would absolutely fire in retaliation
okay but that is an oversimplification
of what nuclear war likely will be so in
your in your example with India and
Pakistan we're not talking about a you
know seven eight Thousand Mile uh launch
of an ICM into space which we all know
is coming and then be like there it is
and we know it's heading for us we can't
stop at fire
Indian what what I what I think that the
mistake is that when you talk about
nuclear war people only think one thing
an ICBM launching from a silo in the
ground in certain in Siberia or in
Oklahoma and then flying through the air
when in reality what's likely going to
happen is Vladimir Putin when he
escalates to nuclear war is going to
take nuclear artillery uh I'm sorry
artillery and it's probably going to use
lower yield gravity bombs 100 kiloton
maybe even getting to the point of a
Megaton these are much much smaller
these days and attacking Ukraine to to
win if he has to No One In The West is
going to retaliate with a nuclear strike
on Russia if Russia uses nukes to win
the war in Ukraine however our our
leaders in the present government
including the National Security advisor
at the White House let's say Jake
Sullivan have have stated many times
that they have communicated to the
Kremlin through the channels they have
and they have them
um that very very severe consequences
would befall Mr Putin and his government
if any kind of nuclear weapon were
introduced into this conflict and and
that's not a U.S retaliatory strike on
Russia right so what would you imagine
would be our our most severe uh
sanctions
if if Russia introduced the most severe
I'd imagine is a U.S declaration of war
and uh I mean really could actually
imagine taking place right yeah I think
there's a strong possibility that
Vladimir Putin were to use tactical
Nuclear artillery or small lower yield
uh weapons nuclear weapons and in
Ukraine that NATO would formally declare
war and the U.S would enter the war and
have a strong probably generate a decent
amount of public support if they come
out and say they just use nukes We're
not gonna just the world will not be
destroyed we must stop this madman and I
I think that's that's very likely so
Putin may be concerned that if he
escalate to that point he gives a Casa's
belly to the west to directly invade and
and engage right now it's it's
relatively passive what the US is doing
that being said Putin is not playing a
game to lose and if pushed to that Brink
I genuinely believe he will be like well
it's either I lose now or I lose against
nato in a year fire the nukes
but we'll see I don't know one aspect of
this is that his military is so depleted
as a result of this
uh catastrophic I don't believe it
misadventure those leaks showed that the
amount of casualties was substantially
less than they've been reporting and
what was it actually was that supposed
to have been doctored wasn't that the
one part of the document that was
supposed to have been Bulldog of War I I
Perhaps Perhaps but I I just think it's
fascinating this idea that Russia which
is a massive economy would have would be
losing to the only country that's become
poorer since the fall of the Soviet
Union but they're not just fighting that
country they're obviously fighting a
coalition that's supplying them and
training them so on U.S veterans look
you don't have to be a military analyst
or
um or have military experience to to to
uh assess this conflict and to be able
to discern accurately that it hasn't
gone well for Russia and that it you
know what what was the I think the
operating premise of both the Russians
and the West at the start of the
conflict was that it wasn't going to
last very long and that they would if
they they had the gumption if they had
the nerve to launch this kind of
violence kinetic military violence in
Europe which had hasn't seen this kind
of thing since World War II if he was
willing to cross that line he was going
to have an easy time capturing Kiev and
deposing the zelenski government well
you know Putin's problem was that he sat
back and let NATO expand for decades and
that was Russia's problem and it's like
only now they're willing to engage in
military conflict they've basically lost
at this point it's it's the craziest
thing to me that you would lose you know
50 percent of the conflicted territory
and then decide to fight it's like you
lost already bro well but also they
already got your border with Estonia and
Latvia now you're mad because because of
Ukraine and gas prom but also look at
the Reliance on the Wagner group okay
which shouldn't be necessary for
world-class military and who is the
Wagner group it you know they're
plucking convicts out of prisons and
throwing them there and even the uh
after the the call-up order that one
went down in September I think it was uh
which met with some extraordinary
displays of resistance on the streets of
Moscow and elsewhere
um you know the reports are that uh and
this is also verified by interception of
uh of signal Communications between
soldiers at the front and their families
and so on but they are throwing even the
the the conscripts into battle with uh
without the sufficient gear making them
pay for their own helmets they can't
even feed them their quarter mastership
alone has been an absolute catastrophe
we heard the same thing about Ukraine
that was that that that guy last year or
whatever who tried to volunteer and then
said it was a disaster people need to
have guns and they were like if you
leave we'll shoot you or whatever but we
but we are we ought to be more surprised
hearing about the Russian military
considering considering but you know I
think you do make the point NATO is it's
basically Russia versus Nato and Ukraine
is being propped up by us I want to jump
to this story and we'll pull this one
into the culture War let's start with
this from the post-millennial US Army
expected to miss recruitment goal again
in 2023 oh boy I sure hope we don't
actually enter World War III with Russia
considering we're not hitting our
recruitment goals I got it maybe there's
something we can do to drum up support
among young people and Inspire them to
be the heroes of Tomorrow to stop the
madman that is Vladimir Putin perhaps I
don't know drag queens
from from Fox News U.S Navy platformed
drag queen influencer to attract youth
to Military and hiring crisis you're
supposed to inspire young overly
testosterone filled dudes to go want to
blow stuff up against the military not
okay just gave you the second Top Gun
and this is how you follow up yeah
seriously Top Gun one of the best
recruitment videos ever the hero's
journey and I see this story and you
know my responses to it I don't care if
you want to be a drag queen by all means
go ahead and do your thing that's a
hobby that's not something you sign up
for to a military service to do yeah
it'd be like talking about how many
girls you ran through or something and
be like oh yeah I got all I got I slept
with 15 women last year joined the army
and you'd be like me like that doesn't
get I mean yeah maybe that would get
guys to join that probably would it'd be
like really women you know dig guys in
uniform huh this is like you're you're
not getting laid you're you're going to
a show to watch watch a man dress like a
woman sing songs
I don't think that's a reason to join
the Navy just you know I see the
photograph and and all I can say is how
far we've come from when Bob Hope used
to bring Raquel Welch over to Vietnam to
entertain the troops you know and she
seemed I'm just going to say I've seen
photos and some films of that it seems
like she was well received on those
occasions why wouldn't they just stick
with that formula you know what I said
when I saw this or everyone's
complaining about it and I was like
isn't the Navy notorious like
notoriously stereotyped for being gay
like like the whole village yeah yeah
yeah yeah in the Navy and then I'm just
like this is not at all surprising to me
but they're like we'll just play to it
it'll be fine but but in all seriousness
when we're seeing recruitment shortages
it is kind of alarming that they're like
I know what's going to make what's going
to make young men want to sacrifice
their lives for the United States drag
queens one less than one percent of the
population I think they're just trying
to give dry cream Queens work you know
they're trying to say like we have the
surplus of drag queens that they can do
anything they can recruit for the
military and they can read to your kids
they can do it all you should be excited
to have a drag queen in your
neighborhood what they ought to be doing
is indoctrinated kids via video games
they got to give really awesome VR or
free video games free download make it
so addictive and awesome and then be
like join the military they had these
video games yeah America's Army but now
imagine you get Call of Duty six or
whatever number they're on and it's like
the story starts and the guy's like I
was on a ship when Harpy Daniels did a
performance and then you're watching a
drag queen and you're like I I don't I
don't feel inspired to die like I want
to go to war to save my country you know
what you know what you know what the
male power fantasy is more like if they
had a guy just like Spider-Man it'd
probably be a lot better literally have
a guy just like Spider-Man and do a
backflip would be better recruitment
than a drag queen like this brings to
mind uh the statement of uh Mike
Huckabee when he was one of the
candidates against Donald Trump in 2016
and they still were having large debates
with the whole field of candidates and
Huck could be said on that occasion
something fairly close to this the
United States military is not a
laboratory for social experimentation
okay it has one Mission which is to
preserve and defend the National
Security and territorial sovereignty of
the United States and I I think I would
wait a long time if I waited for
somebody in the Pentagon to explain to
me how that photo comports with that
there there needs to be Congressional
hearings and dishonorable discharges or
or stripping of rank or something for
the people who are responsible for this
you've got you've already got the meme
of the Russian have you seen the Russian
military ad yes where it's like this
dude's all ripped and he jumps out of a
plane and then lands and you know in the
snow and he puts the mask on he's got
the gun and it's like you are going to
be a hero in Russia then you get the
American ads and it's like I have two
moms and I'm a drag queen and it's like
man you you know look they may not have
the resources they may be having a hard
time with the with you know they're
using old tanks now and they're
recycling old weapons but we're gonna
we're having a Personnel problem yeah we
literally cannot get enough people to go
to boot camp not just because of ads
like this and in apathy but also because
people don't qualify there are more
people turned away because they are
overweight or they struggle with a
mental health disorder they have a drug
use problems that do not qualify for the
military I mean the dod put out this
report saying basically it's like I want
to say 200 000 people every year that
qualify to join the military and of
those around less than 10 percent
actually have an interest in joining I
mean it is a minuscule population who I
really think we should just talk to and
say hey did this commercial with the
drag queen seem appealing to you like
where is the Basic Marketing study where
they gather a bunch of people who
successfully did the thing they wanted
and say would these appeal to you if you
had to do it again because I don't think
this would work it's so profoundly
offensive and it's not so much the drag
queen thing because I'm like I don't
care if people want to do that and have
you know gay men's burlesque it's
America man you go live your life that
you want to do what's offensive is that
they're advertising the Navy is a silly
nonsense
place to be of irresponsibility
it's like if like if made if they made a
commercial and they were like join the
Navy so that you can hang out with your
buddies and eat be you know drink beer
and watch the game I'd be like that's
also that's also bad it's not first I
think this is worse but I mean honestly
you want to dress and drag fine but not
while you're on the service you're in
uniform there maybe on your bed by the
time that's not while you're on duty
that's the other thing there's photos of
this dude protesting and I'm like uh is
he is he allowed to do that as a Navy
serviceman protest holding up a sign for
for abortion look we can we I think we
all agree that
this is not the answer to the
recruitment problem right and so you
know there at a threshold level we
condemn those who who thought that this
somehow would be the answer to that
problem but if you really want to look
at the actual root of the problem itself
it gets to what you said earlier I think
which is you were talking about what's
going to motivate a young person to join
the military which is an all-volunteer
institution uh to potentially give up
their lives right give up their lives
for what for something much larger than
themselves right it has to be something
larger than themselves and as we are as
a society tearing down everything that
the United States has always
historically meant okay you're going to
see fewer people want to lay down their
lives for what remains of that
definition of a country who wants to lay
down their lives for this well it's this
identity thing the military is not about
establishing personal identity it's
about giving up your personal identity
for the group well and I will say the
Surgeon General just came out with
report saying we have an the next Public
Health crisis is loneliness and social
isolation uh do you know what branches
of the military are successfully
reaching their their quotas it's the
Marine Corps it's NASA it's it's things
that people feel like they are part of
something bigger we can identify our
problem and yet we don't apply it to the
institution that apparently needs it
most the military recruitment the Air
Force struggles uh all reservists
struggle the Army struggles the Navy
struggles but yet something that has a
really strong core identity the Marines
and again space force they are doing
okay they're not doing great but they
are making their quotas Trump needs to
get reelected and fire all of these
people just strip them and boot them out
you want to you want to know what you
need to make you want you want a
commercial right now you need some real
propaganda here's what you do you make a
video of a guy in Ukraine and a Russian
soldier is you know firing on some
soldiers and then the guy like grabs a
child and runs from an explosion and
then gives a child to the mother who's
crying and thanks him and he's like go
go go and then the guy turns around and
runs into battle in slow motion and it's
like be the hero join the Army yeah but
it's got to be like an invasion of
Alaska and be like don't let it happen
here so anything anything better than a
guy dressing up like a woman and dancing
you know like that that that's that no
no young man is being like wow that's
why I want to go to a battlefield and
die elephant in the room man when they
discharged all these people out of the
military during this covet crisis and it
was like the most based hardcore dudes
that were like I'm not putting that you
cannot make me I'm here to serve my
country leave me alone let me do my job
and now they were just kicked out now
they're just at men and women and uh
what now now they're all pissed off the
United States like they're gonna come
back I think this is us losing the war
right you know
says win the war before you start it
before fighting it so uh right now we
have recruitment problems and the best
they can come up with this China's like
looking at you know XI Jin thanks look
at his watch like don't invade Taiwan
yet let's let him fester for a little
bit oh they're doing the drag queen
thing okay now we're good once we miss
milled her criminal goals for the fifth
year in a row then then we'll move in I
mean I feel like this is so obvious and
it's happening uh very publicly America
is such a culture exports its culture at
such a high level that there's no way
that this is not part of anyone's
calculation thinking wow they don't have
a healthy population their young people
are uh have higher rates of depression
than anyone else they are not uh looking
to join the military they are feeling
isolated they are a weak country and
therefore we know that ultimately if we
can hold on long enough we can tip the
scales in our favor like that's a very
terrifying thought I'm wondering this is
provocative what's the Chinese military
looking like right now what how are
their massive yeah I would imagine how's
our border defense in Alaska how is the
Canadian border defense on the border of
Alaska there because if the Chinese
decide to join this war right and Canada
has a very very small military and
Trudeau would just absolutely be
deferential to China they would have no
yeah they would have no choice they
could roll into the capital into Alberta
I mean the American Military would be on
the ground but like doesn't Russia
border Canada
it's all very close from Alaska from
Alaska from England's house Sarah Palin
told us and if Taiwan becomes a point
you never actually said that but on
Saturday Night Live
uh but I thought it was in some New
Yorker profile no she said that uh when
it comes so the actual context of what
Sarah Palin said was to be vice
president she would be in a good
position considering Alaska actually
negotiates with Russia over the Bering
Strait and in fact from the westernmost
part of Alaska you can see Russia so
they're often dealing with trade
negotiations as Russian ships are moving
through these territories and then Tina
Fey went on Saturday live and went I can
see Russia from my house and then every
Democrat was like okay I believe through
a pool but that was also true uh George
W bush gave a speech where he was like
who came up with this word because
actually uh is it Will Ferrell or
anything yeah he he was the one who came
up with strategory and George was like
stuck with it yeah he gave a good speech
he was like ah too bad I wish I'd come
up with that one I love the observation
that we need to negotiate peace right
now and if that means concessions to the
Russian army and giving them a piece of
Ukraine I if we don't and we escalate
the Chinese will invade Taiwan with
Russia as their Ally so we're better off
ending this thing with Russia so that
China's afraid to go into Taiwan because
they'll suffer the same kind of losses
that the Russians suffered
what do you think about Taiwan
I'm not sure I think an argument could
be made either way along with the lines
that that Ian was just sketching out
which is to say
Ian's point is if I understood it
correctly which just now was
if we secure a diplomatic resolution to
this conflict right now that makes it
more difficult for China to launch an
invasion of Taiwan
um
whereas you could say that the the
greater
demonstration of resistance that the
West puts up in Ukraine will be more
likely to convince China of the
resistance they would face if they moved
on Taiwan
um I think that if we produce too much
resistance in Ukraine that that China
will have no they'll have a choice but
they'll choose to join the war if the
United States continues to push push
push push push the Chinese and the
Russians they're already building
another economy they're ready to take
control of the world right now and if we
don't end this it's going to escalate
into a multi-faction war and then just
like Hitler took Poland after Mussolini
took North Africa China will take Taiwan
just like Russia is trying to take
Ukraine let me ask I think it's
inevitable but it's better off if we
just get China alone trying to act like
pushing Russia and China together is
insane I'm just saying get out of cities
homeschool kids get some chickens start
to start a little garden because
watching the drag queen Navy thing I've
kind of lost all faith in the U.S
military's capabilities to be completely
honest I think the resistance that's
been shown to Russia is enough to prove
to China that there's going to be insane
resistance in Taiwan if some sort of
military incursion I'm not so convinced
anymore keep it upwards is what you're
saying I I I this like
if you came to me and said do you think
the United States would win I know
sorry recruitment goals missed for what
five years
the United States could win a defensive
War but I mean what's what's that a
bunch of destroyed cities and dead
armies like I mean you look at the crime
you look at the defecation in on the
streets of the United of American cities
you look at the banking crisis these
banks are collapsing I don't feel
confident that if a war started the U.S
would do anything successfully I think
it would just crumble like like a house
of cards
let me ask a question
should we regard that the Chinese
communist state
is foreordained
to failure
for the same reason that the Soviet
Union failed which is to say it is
morally bankrupt at its core like that
that's why we are going to fail because
we're morally bankrupt no I'm saying do
we do you regard the Chinese Enterprise
however strong they might seem in the
moment however much they build up their
military that ultimately the Chinese
Enterprise is foreign to failure because
it is morally bankrupt at its core you
know it's a point because the United
States is morally bankrupted its core as
well so what they both just fail perhaps
the war ends up wiping everybody out so
so you are you are engaging in what they
call moral equivalence you're saying the
U.S and China are equally morally
bankrupt at their core yes
I think so I but but I don't I don't I
don't I don't understand your point I
think the reason the Soviet Union failed
is because they couldn't withstand the
peace we we stayed at peace for too long
they were ready to do some crazy war and
we prevented it but I mean I wasn't
ready for War I think it had to do with
their their economic system being a
total failure yeah
but but China uses capitalist mechanisms
with the the totalitarian Communist
party to controlling all of these things
to have rapid expansion
and they've got a lot of people and uh
they what what they'll do is they'll put
the Communist Party in every major
corporation to control it but let it
function to a certain degree give it
capitalist free reign but always make
sure you've got your tendrils in it so
it can't go outside of your control
which is a potemkin village any any
effort at economic liberalization
without political actual democratization
is a potemkin village right it's not
nobody believes the Chinese assessments
as to their GDP rates you know nobody
the property values are ridiculous it's
all fake in other words if you have uh
Freedom until you reach the boundary of
the Communist party then you don't
really have freedom and I don't care if
you're calling that market reforms or
whatever but but to the point of whether
you know this moral equivalence it
brings to mind a favorite quote of mine
from William F Buckley Jr who uh used to
say when in the 70s when people would
say oh that the CIA and the KGB are the
same guys you know they just they wear
different colored trench coats like in
Spivey spy but like they're they do the
same things and Buckley would say men
men who push old ladies are into the way
of an on-rushing bus and Men Who push
old ladies out of the way of an
on-rushing bus it seems to me ought not
to be grouped together as men who go
around pushing old ladies around so what
happened when the federal government
went to that woman in Alaska's house
because she looked like another woman on
January 6 and they raided her home I
just I I I understand that China is
operating these uyghur concentration
camps and doing very very horrible
things that we're not doing but
my view is while China may be morally
bankrupt to a substantially worse degree
the United States has nothing has no leg
to stand on we've got a corrupt
government that's been corrupt it's been
the country's been extracted for uh its
value its labor being extracted for
decades they've you've got interest in
the United States working with China to
send our labor over there you've got Joe
Biden flying on Air Force two with the
sun to do private Equity deals with
China the United States at this point is
a shell of whatever it may have may have
been a hundred years ago the federal
government for sure but the states are
powerful especially since and and many
of those tickets are rewarding kids at
nine months and giving and and
sterilizing children but look at the
growth of Tim cast look at this
extraordinary operation in what other
country would this have happened I don't
think it could happen any country other
than the United States but but you look
that we we have a a modicum of influence
and power compared to even CNN and it's
funny because people might be but you
just got started in relative terms I
mean they've been around since 1980.
sure I I mean you look at a lot of the
big networks and what happens YouTube
will suppress us every step of the way
and and the tax the tactic they have is
you censor shows like ours at 49 and
prop up shows like CNN at 51 so in the
long run you fail and they succeed they
will absolutely make sure that what
happens fits the corporate algorithmic
structure which is moral Decay and a
psychotic expansion of the woke cult the
United States may very well succeed in
in many regards I'm I'm not completely
uh
I don't think the United States will
cease to exist I think what's going to
happen is if there is a large-scale
global war of some sort we're not
winning it the Petro dollar will fall
the the economic standing in the United
States will be wiped out we will lose
our control on military bases in many
other countries most of the military
bases probably will collapse and fall
into the control of the countries that
they're in and then the people who are
smart enough to get out of cities and
start taking care of themselves will
probably succeed and then we'll see a
new generation of people in the United
States building up becoming economically
resilient starting businesses there it
will not be like the US just ceases to
function but as a global multi-unipolar
world it's done China we're now
multi-polar it's now China the U.S
Russia is clearly you know either I
don't think Russia is going to fall
Russia is probably going to work with
China we may see some Grand War but I
don't see how the U.S actually is able
to pull through considering what we're
witnessing now internally and in our own
military nobody wants to join young
people are completely disaffected their
brains are Shattered by nonsense garbage
social media algorithmic crap like they
actually believe Marxism makes sense
because they don't know what they're
talking about you see these videos of
young people saying the stupidest things
you've ever heard and you're like man uh
Greta tunberg I mean she's not American
but she's outright saying kill 60
million people overnight when she says
we must end fossil fuss now we're not
going to fit it's like okay yeah if you
ended fossil fuels right now like New
York just banned natural gas these
people their brains are broken
this is absolutely a lot about this
they've been they've been wrapped up on
this social media algorithmic garbage
that tells them whatever whatever the
algorithm promotes that's what you must
adhere to so these young people see
climate change as bad then you end up
with a politician saying tell me what to
do so you'll vote for me and they say
bad natural gas things okay no more gas
stoves are you kidding this natural gas
is a large component of how we generate
electricity how about we do nuclear
power no these people are too moronic
because of what they read on the
internet to know nuclear power is clean
and actually the best way to generate
electricity so I see in this country the
cities are corrupt they're decaying the
federal government has corrupt it's a
Decay our best chance in my opinion is
probably Donald Trump Ron DeSantis maybe
a trump DeSantis ticket but that's going
to require a serious amount of force to
go in and start arresting and criminally
charging the corrupt politicians who are
doing insider trading who are illegally
targeting American citizens with unjust
criminal probes they're going to have to
start firing all the bureaucrats and
that's a decade-long project plus you
can't reverse 50 years of corruption
overnight and the problem with all of
that is while Trump may want to do it
he's facing resistance from Nightmare
zombie politicians who just want to get
in office so they can buy and trade
stock while the Titanic sinks I am not
confident in the federal government
outside of the United States and I'm not
confident that we are going to be the
dominant unipolar power I don't even
think we're going to be a superpower in
20 or 30 years there's one word that did
not appear in it in all the you said
God
has a strong lack thereof in this
country
um
in other words if you regard that the
cities are corrupt and you regard that
the federal government is corrupt
um those are two large sectors right
there right of of our society federal
government municipal government uh what
does that leave you've got
business right which I presume you also
regard as hopelessly corrupt absolutely
is that nothing about woke it's just
mindlessly corrupt and has been okay so
then there's you know uh one uh
traditionally anyway there was one other
major Power Center in this country that
had the the ability to to move people to
motivate people and even to feed people
and that was
the churches right and faith and so I
just that's why I bring it up yeah we
need to see that we need Collective
Consciousness something's changed this
country has experienced a severe moral
and uh communal Decay over the past
couple decades and this past these past
10 years have been a rapid acceleration
of it to the point where starting at
around 2016 2017 you started to see
serious conversations in corporate press
about Civil War and the real Prospect of
it a Princeton Professor coming on I
think it was like MSNBC saying we are in
a cold Civil War you start seeing
factions fighting in the streets you're
seeing crime running rampant in in all
of our major cities with no willpower to
do anything about it in fact in Chicago
despite the fact that crime is
increasing and people don't feel safe
there they elected an even further left
politician so I that's why I say get out
of these cities do I think we as the
United States will get through this I
really do but the night is always
darkest before the dawn if you want to
stay in these places it's going to get
bad if China wants to take Taiwan we may
resist but they're probably going to get
it I I just
looking at how the federal government is
acting what I see as our best path
forward is Trump getting an office
following through with schedule F we
need some serious criminal justice
action I'm talking getting an AG who
starts going to Department apartment and
issuing criminal indictments on say
people in the FBI for targeting American
citizens with trumped-up BS and ignoring
the far left extremists who have done
comparable things I believe though that
if he did that without the Consciousness
the will of the Consciousness he'd be
killed by the CIA overnight and then
well there well then that's that's a
black film I think we need to rename
this show the Grim cast Okay that's
where we're at regardless they're more
black pill than others oh God you
brought up God if we were to start
believing in God as a culture again
God doesn't win Wars God doesn't build
businesses how would understanding God
and bringing people together under that
help us become a society God provides
fuel for those Enterprises
when we talk about belonging to
something larger than ourselves
um God encompasses that in my view
unified moral Focus
if everyone said we all agree look I'll
put it this way uh we've talked to many
people who are religious I am not a
Christian I do believe in God but I
firmly believe and this is obvious if
every single person in this country had
the same faith
you wouldn't really need law enforcement
you would to a small degree but you
wouldn't have to worry too much if
everyone 100 was faithful or yeah or
practiced that's a practice Yeah if
everybody was devout 100 there would be
absolutely no no need for law
enforcement at all if men were angels we
would have no need of government right
yeah and so what you actually end up
getting is to varying degrees a large
portion of a population having one moral
framework and thus you don't see a lot
of crime but then you have some people
who just genuinely don't care or through
crimes of desperation commit crime so
you'll need some kind of law enforcement
or policing or communal watch or defense
or something like that right now what we
have is a completely shattered social
infrastructure with no moral framework
at all and woke people who these younger
people that are growing up have no moral
framework at all we here on this show
have a solidly whether anyone any
liberal or whatever wants to admit it in
the United States I sadly Christian
moral framework I bring this up very
often Bill Maher has a Christian moral
framework in his world view he believes
in the presumption of innocence which is
rooted in the story of Sodom and
Gomorrah which is where blackstone's
formulation comes from which is where we
get our our fifth amendment and Fourth
Amendment and other amendments but you
look at the woke generation now you look
at the younger generation they don't
care about any of that they've actually
come out against the Constitution they
have protested saying we should get rid
of it they don't believe in in
fundamental rights because they don't
have the same moral framework we do
their moral framework is rooted in the
fascistic view there is no truth but
Power I believe this we have to win that
war like Judaism is is I I'm finding
myself more Jewish by the day and I
think what's happened is these global
banking cartels
are sometimes run by people with Jewish
ancestry and they're they might not even
believe in God but they call themselves
Jewish and they're poisoning the name of
the Jew and taking credit for something
that I want to see it I want to see you
behave like a Jew if you are you show me
it's it's about you don't worship money
like how can you fathom setting up a
bank and and taking interest from people
that they can't afford
I think part of it is the banks are
collapsing but anyway I was thinking I
think the youngest generation is so lost
because we are a culture that didn't
Safeguard our morals I understand uh
objections to organize religions people
feel like any institution you know
churches can become corrupt but we
didn't raise children in a collective
understanding of what's good and what's
wrong we raise children in a culture
that said you know push your boundaries
constantly anything is whatever you want
to be it was a very ambiguous time and
this has been going on since since the
80s and I think as a result we have a
generation of people who are uh in many
respects hopeless and lost and that is a
very difficult thing to come back from
because bitterness is a pill you can't
follow let me show you this story from
CNN I want to talk about this Tucker
Carlson thing Tucker Carlson sent a
racist text to a producer quote it's not
how white men fight silly you have this
story uh what What's his name Abby
something Grossman is their name I guess
grossberg there you go and she was uh
coming out being like oh they were so
bad to me they were so awful
so what happens is Tucker Carlson
releases a text where he says I saw this
video of proud boys beating up an antifa
guy and I started getting into it saying
I could taste it and then I realized you
know this I shouldn't be thinking these
things is bad I don't want to be in this
place here's what CNN does they show the
first part of the quote that makes it
look like Tucker is just bloodthirsty
they then give you this massive story
about fox and dominion and text messages
and a lawsuit and settlement before they
give you the actual quote which is
Tucker saying these are bad things we
shouldn't think these things and that's
my point because what happens is people
will read the first quote once they get
down to the part about Dominion old news
from a month ago they'll just stop
reading I think about this person Abby
grossberg and this is what this nation
has raised people to be mindless
self-indulgence they see that you can be
popular by saying whatever the machine
wants you to say they they are quite
literally slaves to the AI already
if they can get likes from it they'll
say it they don't care what it is if
they don't get likes from it they won't
say it even if it's right like an
episode of Black Mirror absolutely and
so now what you have a generation of
people who are like don't know don't
care I will say whatever gets traffic
and there's this really funny clip
actually let me pull it up because I
have it and it's from the Tim it's from
Tim Dillon's podcast that perfectly
exemplifies the vapid despicable nature
of these young people uh here we go I'm
gonna pull this up right here uh let me
play this clip for you guys to be honest
like it's it's actually really hard in
the space right like we have like 45
seconds to record a video keeping
people's attention and a lot of people
on our side like if they start hearing
like I've actually done it before I've
criticized like a Democrats like
specifically Hakeem Jeffries and it all
just went South like I started losing
followers like it's bad right and I
really want to be that person that like
reaches the other side because Democrats
I mean they're horrible at their jobs
right they do a lot of shitty things
although I'll vote for them all the time
but it's also hard in the space to
criticize that's a good can we clip that
quote they're horrible please please
don't please don't please don't click
for them please no no no no please to be
honest like he legit was like no no
please don't clip that please and when I
first heard this kid said that I thought
it was him more snorkeling be like don't
clip it come on guys but he actually
sounds scared and this is it these two
young men they're paid by by a talent
agency that gets money from the DNC they
go on the internet and just say mindless
vapid garbled nonsense that sounds like
politics but has no bearing in reality
they get followers from it if they
deviate from that line they lose
followers we can have Luke gradkowski
come on the show and rant about how he
doesn't like Donald Trump and people
still like and follow Lou gradkowski
because whatever space we're in we're
more interested in having an honest
conversation and explaining our ideas
even if it challenges my or someone
else's opinion people will still be like
well I want to hear what these people
think and why that whole thing is a cult
and this is what young people are being
raised to do
it doesn't matter what Tucker Carlson
was actually trying to say what matters
is how can we extract cult responses how
can we extract followers zombies I don't
see how the United States remains a
dominant power if it even still is if
half or more of this country are either
lazy ignorant willfully ignorant or
willfully manipulative like these young
men
even 30 are you about to say something I
just I I personally recoil from
generational disparagement you know I I
it's because you have children and you
want to believe it can take the future
back no my kids are irretrievable no
um only because
um you know we could talk about kind of
pajama guy I don't know if you remember
that it was from like I don't know maybe
it was the Obama era and there was there
was there were ads that were created to
promote Obamacare and one of them showed
this sort of a feet looking guy in his
pajamas and he you know it he was
dressed in red flannel pajamas and he
had a little cup of java and he had sort
of hornroom glasses
okay and yeah that's right yeah we
pulled this up so it might be tempting
to sort of uh to to write off the
current generation of young people as
pajama guy or you know they're just
completely wrapped up in their
artificial Cocoon of of you know their
phones and social media and everything
else but
uh you know I just getting older I
recognize that these were these are glib
distinctions to say that a one
generation had grit and understood and
this generation doesn't and that's a
fact that you'd never be the guy that's
like kids today compare any of the
generations since World War II well with
the kids that were grown up in the
internet you brought this up before the
show the kids that were born into the
age of the internet don't have the
reference of knowing what it's like
without the machine it's one thing
sometimes it's one thing to say when the
Boomers uh when the greatest generation
is talking about the Boomers and you're
like don't criticize the younger
generation everybody does it there's
that quote from Socrates about how they
got no respect and then after several
Generations you've come to the point
where gen Z is morbidly obese lazy
demanding safe spaces full of cotton
candy because people said naughty words
on campus and you compare that to the
greatest Generation who stormed the
beaches of Normandy but again aren't how
many uh members of this current
generation that were so quick to dismiss
are are
um the heroes who are responding it's
school shootings or are in the military
and doing extraordinary things who are
missing our recruitment goals and the
Uvaldi cops did nothing and the cops in
the security guard in Parkland ran away
so now what we're seeing is there was a
story in Philadelphia where a man raped
a woman on the train and not a single
person did anything to help that's where
we are with our current generation does
the name Kitty Genovese ring a bell has
anyone heard of Kitty Genovese so Kitty
Genovese was a woman in Queens in 1964
and she lived in a big apartment
building that had a central Courtyard
area and she was attacked and raped
repeatedly and killed and she died from
her injuries and the investigation this
is 1964 which as far as I'm concerned is
modernity
and the investigation determined that
there were several dozen people who were
aware of the attack who were witnessing
it take for different parts of it take
place not one single person called the
police and the Kitty Genovese case
endures as a model of urban sociology
it's been taught for 50 years in college
courses and what was the reason that
nobody called the cops and as opposed to
your example on a subway where nobody
lifted a finger you're right there in
the thick of it you might be afraid that
you're going to get slashed or whatever
here was a situation where these several
dozen people in this apartment complex
looking down on their Courtyard didn't
even face the hurdle of personal
exposure to Danger right they just had
to pick up a phone and nobody did and
why didn't they I bet I know because
they all thought somebody else was going
to do it correct okay so you know when
you cite an example like that one on the
subway as an example of today's morality
depraved morality on the part of a given
generation then we can talk about
Kitty Genovese from 1964 which was a
generation by and large with much
greater Civic sense yes yes yes but I'm
saying it just has gotten worse like I'm
not comparing those people to the people
who stormed the beaches of Normandy I I
absolutely agree that Generations have
increasingly gotten worse now what we're
dealing with there is two singular
stories that it's you know the plural of
anecdote is not data we have these
stories they're interesting but I think
when you look at what's happening with
our universities you take a look at the
fact that movies they're they're firing
they fired Sarah Silverman I think that
she got fired from a movie because she
did a blackface joke 15 years prior
mocking the idea we're in a generation
now where you have college students
screaming at professors that this is not
about education it's about safe spaces
look there's a lot of troubling
phenomena out there in with the current
Generation all I'm saying is that if I
were on that day where I have the
supernumery
Reese's Peanut Butter Cup that I just
shouldn't right and I plopped to the
ground
um I'm pretty sure it's going to be a
person of the current generation who's
going to get me to uh that's the
hospital who's going to take care of her
but again anecdotal but I think it's
important so is your Subway story so and
I said that I said quite literally your
story in minor anecdotals I'm willing to
step back and say and let's let's
multiply it by you know Millions so I
don't like making statements about
Generations so so let's do that let's
talk about let me ask you a question do
you think that if a woman is nine months
nine months pregnant and at the point of
birth a doctor should be allowed to kill
the baby
so you're asking about my personal
political opinions which I'm not
supposed to give because I'm a reporter
so let's just put it this way you don't
have to answer that question okay in
Colorado a woman can be at the point of
birth at the point and a doctor can kill
the kid the Democrats tried passing a
law allowing basically
Limitless abortion for the health of the
mother and there was interesting ways
they described what that really meant it
could mean depression and things like
that we went to a great detail we're at
a point now where
our standard and using abortion as one
single example you have states that have
said No Limit you have states that have
banned it outright a complete
hyperpolarization of morality in this
country you have people uh you have
states that are advocating for child
sterilization with sex change surgery
despite the fact that the universities
and Medical Practice in Europe have
already abandoned it they don't care
about what makes sense I I think it is
not that I'm saying that we're we're
going to lose but there is a very clear
moral decay in this country with the
current generation that didn't exist
with the previous generation and now
again I'm not giving any of my own
opinions because I'm not paid to do so
although I'm willing to explore those
options with Tim cast but here you are
talking about moral Decay and the person
whom you have identified just in the
course of our conversation as the only
person who can possibly start the great
rescue effort of the United States that
urgently needs to be undertaken is
Donald Trump that's right okay who is uh
married three times yep um you know
under under indictment uh presently
facing on uh rape trial
that's quite literally the moral Decay
to which I'm referring a 30 year old
case that clearly appears to be
fabricated a false accusation that he
was working for Russia Ukraine gate
clearly something Joe Biden was doing
engaging in a quid pro quo and are
morally decade country indicted Trump
for figuring it out rather accidentally
Trump is not a saint he's a lewd
lascivious old man and it's scary that
he is our best chance but when you talk
when you when you you don't you don't
think maybe politically but I think it's
in the music he's he's in the bus saying
you can grab the women they let you do
it yeah I'm not I'm not gonna come out
and be like you know what the left is
saying about him he said they let you
fine whatever but it is fairly you know
locker room talk whatever you want to
call it Trump is not a saint but Trump
is at the very least someone who's I
would say our only chance at getting rid
of the first layer of crust that has
taken over our our uh and all the other
potential Republican um uh contenders
who whose names we all know
um you regard as as hopelessly corrupt
well like like who
DeSantis the Santa I think is good
that's why I said a trump DeSantis
ticket is probably pretty good I think
it's a good job but I think DeSantis is
going to negotiate and what that will do
is just be another sludge in the machine
of slowly moving forward whereas Trump's
going to go in like a ball in a china
shop and just start saying enough we
need the ground swell because the head
does nothing without the body's
attention and so the people the
generation I think this is why
institutions to be brought up don't
demonize generations of humans because
the every generation faces its own
you know its own coming to God moment
its own struggle and overcoming of it
and this generation is facing it and a
lot of them are failing they've been
sucked into the machine and have become
something they're not or that they
weren't or that they don't want to be or
they don't understand but there's a lot
of great ones and it's we're speaking to
all of them especially the ones that are
listening you lit right now like I don't
know what 30 40 of our audience is
between the ages of 18 and 34 like we've
got a lot of you listening right now and
it is you that is going to change the
world and hold this thing together so
what I'm what I'm saying is not that
every single person that exists is bad
I'm saying that Millennials have a very
serious malignancy and so does gen Z
something that we've not seen in the
past in the 1990s I grew up in Chicago
as as a Democrat as Democrat could be
and I worked at a bunch of non-profits
when I got older I did register the vote
actions and uh I I thought I liked Obama
until you know he started blowing up
kids and obviously the stuff he did to
you is really bad but that was what my
family believed in and when it came to
abortion as a really good moral example
the argument that I would hear from my
Urban liberal Democrat friends was no
none of us like it we all think abortion
is bad but it's not an issue for
government it's an issue of medical
practice so we agree at a certain point
maybe it should not be allowed but the
government shouldn't intervene within a
certain amount of time now the argument
is that that female comedian going on
Netflix saying everybody get an abortion
you get an abortion you have Lena Dunham
going out and saying she wished she had
one despite not being pregnant she's
like I I never got one but I wish I did
that is absolute chaos and moral Decay
that didn't exist in the previous
generation and we're seeing that get
crazier and crazier to the point where
Washington and Colorado are creating
sanctuaries for child sex changes like
it's just come on you know in in Sweden
Finland Denmark they say okay we're
going to stop doing these things that
don't work the Tavistock Center in the
UK is being shut down in the United
States the Democrats are codifying law
to take 10 year olds and give them
hormones that sterilize them and I'm
just like okay The Thirst for power and
money knows no bounds the doctor in
Florida who made videos saying she was
going to eat teats today and talked
about you know she gets she she makes
tons of money giving young girls double
mastectomies because they're going
through some kind of psychological
trauma this is moral Decay that did not
exist now don't get me wrong lobotomies
happened and then everybody was like yo
these are bad things you stopped doing
it but today there's a bifurcation it
feels like the traditional left and
right Paradigm is in one camp and then
this new morally psychotic algorithmic
mess is the left yes first time that the
International Community is heavily
influenced the United States like this I
think the hardest thing is you don't
want to demonize a whole generation I
think you're right but on the other hand
we have to be honest with the challenges
that they're facing and the way that the
generations before them have prepared
them to Take On The World Is Not serving
them you're part of this generation you
should say we not they I'm talking about
Millennials I'm a millennial yeah I
think Millennials are garbage I think
they're no you guys are awesome man
Millennials are over Millennials are are
the look Gen X is fantastic I think
genetics is great thank you very much
yes Gen X and Boomers and I am willing
to praise whole Generations oh okay
pretty awesome but here's here's how I
view it you have gen xers which are net
positive but maybe it's 60 40. there's a
decent amount of people in their 40s and
50s who are very weak and allow this
kind of stuff to take over you then get
the millennial generation which inverts
where very few Millennials are of strong
moral character and overwhelmingly are
vapid narcissistic social media driven
individuals gen Z actually might be
slightly more based than Millennials
because we're starting to see a bunch of
young people protest the The algorithmic
psychosis that Millennials were
entrenched in so I think that may be a
net positive but gen Z is still fairly
even better gen Z is better than
Millennials I think but Millennials are
and that I'm a manual I think
Millennials are the worst well the thing
I like about Z and Millennials is that
they're involved the problem with Gen X
and I'm not speaking for everybody
because obviously James you and I are
actually I'm like tail end of it you're
earlier or in the middle of it somewhere
is that they checked out a lot of Gen X
is just checked out well the name of the
movie was Slackers right I mean that was
one of the sort of iconic movies from
the Gen X period
um we were talking about this before we
started the show and um yeah I was born
in 1968. so I turned 10 in the year
1978. you know where an evening's
entertainment was you watch TV one of
the three channels maybe you had a VHS
machine but you played board games you
know what I'm saying and like there were
times of the day that were set aside
generally the morning and 6 p.m
and in those times if you wanted to be
engaged in the business of acquiring
information those were the times when
you did that otherwise you were living
your life and I'm very grateful to have
experienced a time before computers took
over everything so so what I see
with
the Boomers for instance is that we had
a lot of great content in the 90s you
know having grown for the 90s I'm biased
for sure and uh the Gin Blossoms oh my
God but uh what a great band I I think
it's in Road man I think about where we
are culturally today and especially with
AI and algorithms and what that's
leading to it's static it's chaos and
where we were in the 90s and before that
and it just feels like an unraveling you
know
that is certainly I feel like a an
attack a psychological attack by Foreign
interests corporate interests to try and
disrupt the the people of the United
States it does it's not a natural thing
that just happened because these people
are who they are I think it's just a
result of the internet right I mean
exactly to your point there were there
was limited connection to the outside
world you got information at certain
times otherwise you were more engaged
with your family life in your community
I don't think when we had the internet
which of course is a great blessing in a
lot of ways we knew what it was like we
didn't know we'd have to put it back in
the box right we didn't know that at
some point you would hand a 12 year old
a smartphone and say like okay be
careful on this you could get
semi-addicted to it and be constantly
seeking dopamine hits through people
online we didn't know what we were
bringing up and that's why I think it's
so important to talk about the
challenges that specifically face the
youngest Generations in this country
because they're unlike any generation
before them or still we're hearing that
crazy story about Roblox do you guys
hear about this one no tell me predators
are going on Roblox because they know
there's no parents and it's all kids and
then they start indoctrinating these
kids and saying creepy things to them
and exploiting them
and that's but I think that also
happened on like do you remember
RuneScape yeah my brother used to play
that and like you would get people being
like oh let me give you your phone
number or whatever else like these these
uh again very morally corrupt people
will find a way to use technology that
we think is innocent to for negative and
nefarious men and this this is what
we're seeing with drag queen Story Hour
is it's gotten to the point where the
left establishment is protecting the
exploitation of children to rather
extreme degrees like the sterilization
of children and uh let's let you know
what I'm gonna play this clip so I can
explain to you moral bankruptcy in a way
that I think you might say oh man
let me uh let me see if I can pull this
up from the post-millennial I'm always
I'm always up for some good moral
bankruptcy yeah in whatever form you
want to feed it to me you know you can
go bankrupt and still be very wealthy I
found out uh there is this phenomenon I
think where people in this modern
generation feel like they're failing if
they're not on the internet if they're
not connected it's a sort of failure but
the reality is the inverse taking 10
days away from the internet can make
your life magnitudes better great 100
times better I'm gonna play for you this
clip from
a major television network
and uh warning to all those you may have
heard it before it's disturbing
with her I'm worried about like her
mental
well-being and her dilation the minute
she leaves my house we have a dilation
problem that is a concern when you don't
have that watchful eye they tend to go
back to Old patterns I have woken Jazz
out of a dead sleep and taken the
dilator and put the lubrication on it
and said here you take this and you put
it in your vagina if not I will but jazz
is bad even when I'm home once a day I
will be so mad at the machine
goes away in college and that thing
seals up I bring her neck can you
imagine this is a story about a
biological male this entire discussion
was beyond my technical kin so let me
explain let me let me let me say it for
you as plainly and ineffective but yeah
all right I am not going to explain this
to people in a way that will in invite
invective or aggression I will just try
and keep the language plain this is the
story about jazz Jennings a biological
male who at the age of three was
determined to be transgender by Jazz's
family began social transition around
seven puberty blockers hormone blockers
at the age of 17 as a minor Jazz
received which caught received uh a sex
change operation they referred as bottom
surgery typically an adult male
reception what age 17 as a minor
typically people receive what's called a
penile inversion vaginoplasty if they're
adults but because Jazz underwent
puberty blockers Jazz did not develop
any physical function in in terms of
sexual components this resulted in
severe complications and multiple
surgeries where they take stomach lining
to create the inside of what is a
permanent wound in the pelvis of this
young male the purpose for which is so
that a man who is attracted to this to
this to Jazz can insert themselves for
sexual gratification
after the surgery because the wound
tries to seal itself you have to
introduce what's called a dilator every
day which is a a device that cranks the
wound open with lubrication this is the
story of a mother on The Learning
Channel a major corporate cable channel
explaining how she wakes up her
biologically male child in the middle of
the night and says stick this in your
wound and crank it open or I will and
then goes on to say if she leaves and
that wound closes I will ring her neck
tell me this is not moral Decay when on
cable television this which I believe to
be purely criminal child abuse is
celebrated I see that and I just say we
have reached a severe state of moral
decay
it's a kind of it sounds like a
psychosis
Collective psychosis and the idea that
it would be presented on any sort of
viable commercial television Outlet of
some kind
is staggering to me and you know Ron
DeSantis hasn't filed any criminal
charges against his family for what
they've done it's gotten to the point
where I'll phrase it this way if it was
uh 1990 and we heard a story about a
parent who did this to their child
they'd probably be arrested investigated
the child would be removed given
Psychotherapy and some kind of help
this is this is to this to the point
where not only is look
there are people in this country who are
mad at me right now for saying this this
woman says that she forces her child to
do this
her child clearly does not want to
that's why she has to wake up her child
in the middle of the night and say do it
or I will for a TV show and instead of
saying maybe we should investigate
because this sounds like abuse this
sounds like the child does not want to
engage in this practice and the mother
is making them do it and it could be
potentially harmful why don't we get
Protective Services or some kind of law
enforcement to at least investigate not
only are we not doing that we're putting
it on television celebrating it giving
them commercials and their books and
Jazz has a book encouraging more
children she's engaging this jazz is an
adult now which is why there's no
protective custody thing going in now
it's just you would assume it's a
consensual relationship between two
consenting adults otherwise Jazz would
have files let me play this other clip
because people are requesting I play
this other clip here well listen to this
are you feeling like
to start talking
are you okay I'm okay I'm gonna get them
to cry
but you know I can't get out of my yeah
I know no listen it just doesn't stop
it's okay give me a hug it's okay I know
what you're going through we've been
there no weed still doesn't stop now and
I'm already going back to negative but
the more you're talking about yourself
it gets harder you're digging in and
you're it's making you put a magnifying
glass on what's already difficult as it
is
so this is hard for you I know and you
don't we don't want to push it I know
I'm the one doing it like I know you're
almost enemy
I feel kind of all over the place and
like my mind is very cluttered and not
clear and I really want to have that
Clarity I really want to understand
myself and be able to read my own soul
and what I want and it's just very
challenging and I think I'm kind of
breaking down a little bit and spiraling
into negativity
I just want to feel like myself like
that's it I don't care all I want is to
be happy and feel like me and I don't
feel like we ever
so
the interesting thing with this now is
that jazz a biological male who was
raised as a female underwent surgery is
dating women
this to me is is
obvious moral Corruption of our of our
society in ways we've not seen in
previous generations I'll tell you what
it brings to mind for me
it brings to mind
uh the statement from John Kenneth
Galbraith raise your hand if you know
John Kenneth Galbraith was he was an
economist he coined the term the
affluent society and he was also
President Kennedy's ambassador to India
and uh he and Buckley used to have a
kind of a relationship sort of like
Scalia and RBG where he had these two
people on different sides of the of the
issues who would debate and they were
best friends they would go skiing
together Etc but John Kenneth Galbraith
said I think around 1960 that America is
the first country in the history of the
world
where more people are at risk of dying
from having too much to eat than from
having too little and the choices that
and the decision making and the
Enterprise that you've just played
is is are the choices and decisions and
and the Enterprise of an elective
Society
where you know if you go around the
world uh or if you go into other
neighborhoods in the United States where
they don't have enough to eat
no one's doing this sort of thing
yeah I mean I think it's important to
note that this
was something that boiled up over time
right this this was something that uh
crept up to be at the point where we now
talk about it as if it's a regular part
of society Jazz's show used to be on TLC
TLC also hosted uh 19 Kids and Counting
which were Jim Bob and Michelle Duggar
who were these homeschooling Christians
and they were sort of another of you at
an extreme family because that's how TLC
made money for years and years and years
they took people who lived in sort of
unorthodox ways or not in a normal way
and put them both on TV and one of the
sons-in-law Derek Dillard on Twitter
this is I think this was in like
2006 16 maybe 2014. uh said you know
jazz is being abused this is not real
you know there's only two genders and
this is all terrible and TLC said he can
appear on the show anymore he is not
allowed to be on this thing where
theoretically he makes money because
they sided with the gender ideology and
this was I mean close to a decade to go
at this point we have seen this coming
for some time and instead of intervening
and saying like well let's at least have
both opposing opinions on air and let
people sort it out for themselves you
know I know you always say this but
people saw well this one makes more
money so we'll side with it I don't even
know if it does make more money uh but
there is there is a
when you look back it's sort of dark to
think that along the way we could have
had rational discussions and we could
have said I don't know maybe this is too
far maybe there are some boundaries
we're crossing and instead we're like no
we need to let people live as they live
even when you sacrifice a child body
basically when I saw Rachel dolezal
she was the lady out in in the Seattle
area I think who uh you know transracial
who became convinced that she identifies
as an African-American person
and you know took every step possible to
further that idea including changes in
the way she presented herself and so on
but she got as far with it as securing
the position I think of executive
director of the local NAACP out there
okay she she got to be in charge of an
organization for that advanced the
interests of of people of color even
though she herself was white and when I
saw that take place I thought to myself
well what should prohibit me from saying
that from the age of five I have
strongly identified as a beetle and I'm
going to demand that all of you anyone
who comes into my presence and and all
of you who don't shall now treat me
as a beetle that starts with the checks
but that's not the end of it right like
yeah the sixth Beetle you know
um I suppose well there's the drummer
and then I guess you could say original
original Paul the first ball oh yeah I
am the I am the six millionth font fifth
Beatle is what I have but you know
again these are this wouldn't this isn't
happening what you just played the Jazz
Jennings Saga isn't happening in in
places where people are scrounging just
to have enough to eat right these are
the decisions the elective decisions of
an affluent society and what's moral
Decay and it's just extraordinary are
you familiar with the rat hope
experiment no scientists put a bunch of
rats in a space limited space unlimited
resources food and water and then
observed what they would do and they
broke down to the point where
like they were uh huddling around each
other no longer engaging in normal right
Behavior one one group started grooming
themselves and did nothing else their
behavior started to break down they
became aggressive they would with the
limited amount of space they would all
congregate in one small area right they
uh the the social breakdown resulted in
like stopping eating and then dying when
they would take one of the rats from
this place and put it back into a normal
rat Society it would retain the social
behaviors and spread them and then bring
social Decay so that's very horrifying
behavioral sync the rat Utopia I think
you may have said rat uh sorry it's a
different one The Hope was a different
one put them in water and make them swim
but it's the rat yeah hope one's scary
too yeah when you give people unlimited
food
you know how how do you convince them
not to eat too much become a Christian
become a Jew like don't gluttony is a
sin for a reason well the difference is
cities are like the rat Utopias but you
can still get out to the country and get
away from these congested areas so the
difference is
in the in the rat Utopia they stayed in
one place in the human Utopia people who
are seeing the Decay are fleeing and the
people who are absorbing the Decay are
staying and they're making TV shows
about the people that are staying there
that's right and then they're
broadcasting it to the entire world and
saying look how profitable it is if
you're like that and but but make a show
out of you Jazz can't have children
so
you know the people of this moral
ideology eventually from aborting their
children and sterilizing their children
are less likely to reproduce and share
those ideologies they try to go to
schools but conservatives have started
pulling their kids out and engaging in
homeschooling so I think rather
optimistically for bad reasons the
future is more likely to course correct
and this will naturally resolve itself
yeah well these kind of movements which
are stalinist at their core ultimately
become self-devouring
you know my feeling about this is that
um in 1954 we had Brown V Board of
Education right The Landmark Supreme
Court ruling that overturned Plessy V
Ferguson from 1896 which had said
separate but equal as constitutional
right and after Brown V Board of Ed
it was no longer lawful or
constitutional for a state system to
discriminate against somebody based on
their color
and then there were subsequent Supreme
Court rulings which
um you know I think brownview Board of
Ed mandated desegregation quote with all
deliberate speed but there was a I think
it's Alexander V Holmes I've forgive me
for not remembering off the top of my
head but there was a 1969 Supreme Court
ruling which took it further and said
not with all deliberate speed now okay
so African-Americans were and remain a
minority group okay I think they
comprised 13 of the American population
let's assume it was roughly the same in
1954. this was a minority group that was
terribly aggrieved and sought uh
redressed through the courts and
succeeded
and ever since then what you've had is
every minority group
some of them with far less compelling
claims to being grieved
they're all seeking their Brown V Board
of Ed moment well hold on the left today
black lives matter for instance they
want to reverse Brown V Board of Ed uh
Derek Bell for instance spoke out
against it saying it was wrong and he
agreed with Plessy B Ferguson so if
they're allowed to continue down that
path we'll get segregation and in fact
they've reintroduced segregation in many
universities well this would be the
difference between the civil rights
movement and and BLM but
um in short what you're seeing with this
fight over bathrooms and the whole
transgender question is a a minority
group that that has its own sense of
aggrievement and which is seeking to use
uh the the courts and and other
traditional means to redress this to
their satisfaction now when everyone saw
the the TV broadcasts of the film
footage of sheriff Bull Connor you know
sicking dogs and and and fire hoses and
billy clubs on innocent African-American
demonstrators the
um the the horror was so vivid and and
readily discernible that no one would
quarrel with
um with with a ruling like brownview
Board of Ed the the policy was so
self-evidently discriminatory
um and and if and there was so much
interaction between uh the majority and
the minority group here I remember
seeing Cory Booker on the very first
debate that was held for the 2020 cycle
it was in late June of 2019 and you had
so many Democratic candidates at that in
June of 2019 they had to have two
programs back to back uh with what they
called the Kids Table
um and Cory Booker you know he's been
around for a while people in Washington
certainly know who he is but perhaps
this was his chance really to introduce
himself to the American electorate writ
large and maybe he wouldn't get an
another better chance and as it happened
he didn't but I remember him saying in
that debate we must spend more time
talking about trans Americans and in
specific African-American trans
Americans to tepid Applause
we're talking about a a minority here
that is a fraction of a fractions okay
and yet look at the extraordinary
attention that's paid to this look at
the resources that are consumed with it
look how much time we're spending
discussing it okay and that is because
but we're not talking about that small
amount we're talking about I think 47
000 young people in the past four years
have been put on sterilizing chemicals I
think that's fairly substantive that
establishment medical practices are
engaging in this Behavior to this degree
and we're in the thousands of young
girls who have had their breasts removed
and we're talking about 15 year old
girls right no but you're taught what
I'm talking about is the success of a
very very small minority in uh bringing
its grievance to the Big Show but but
this is my point it's not a small
minority it is powerful establishment
political forces bringing this issue
being co-opted or aligning themselves
with this tiny tiny minority but but
it's it's it's
a child who doesn't know what any of
this is being brought to a doctor to
have her breasts removed is not a member
of a community seeking civil rights
Justice it is an adult who is not it is
jazz ending's mother is not a trans
person Jazz Jennings mother introduced
her three-year-old child to this right
so it's not the minority but we do have
to go to super church
because eight minutes no no oh you
answered it okay so uh if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button head over to timcast.com become a
member so we uh you can watch the
uncensored members only show coming up
at about 10 10 p.m but let's read your
super chats I'm not your buddy guy says
this is Canada a conservative MP had had
his family threatened in China and the
Liberals silenced him saying it would be
debunked despite csis confirmation I
mean the CCP had threatened his family
in China
interesting
gravity says Tom McDonald should be
protected at all costs for this country
change my rooster mind buck buck Tommy
Donald is fantastic he has a new song
Dirty Money you guys should definitely
check it out supporters work
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim at first I
was angry about the weak willed wants to
understand white rage run in our
military into degradation then recalled
living on a ship for a year with Sailors
and well sounds about right unfortunate
Robert Knight says the Fed rate hike
today will destabilize the banking
industry more Powell didn't rule out
another rate hike in June this unfurling
and dangerously also expect Energy
prices to spike in summer definitely
with air conditioning
Joe Joel Stein says re yesterday's convo
about sponsoring a sports team you
should put a picture of your big Roberto
Jr on the hood of a NASCAR cup series
car the first car comes to mind you are
a wrecking ball I don't know if I can
afford that have you heard about Roberto
Jr no we have a chicken Colony I'm
probably not the one who can there's
Babies we have babies new babies and
this is part of chicken Tim's personal
interest and also sort of the cultural I
don't know movement to grow again so
Roberto Jr is is the the lead chicken
one and only Roberto was yeah and then
he had a son now he is the king but
Roberto had to retire because he was
banging his daughters and you can only
allow that for so long dirty yeah no
chickens it's called line breeding
actually so you can do like a generation
but you don't want to keep doing it and
so then we introduce Roberto Jr but now
we're getting to the point where Roberto
Jr may have to get his own private
mansion with some girls because you know
now he's he's he's become he's part of
the very problem he was intended so I
think Roberto Jr has if people has one
child but uh big news the silkies had
four babies and the coaching had two
babies so uh wow
for you Tim as Emperor who will you
designate as the uh the next Viceroy
when Junior steps down or is removed
from power man that's tough maybe maybe
we'll give little Luke his Reign I like
it Ian to see you shamelessly lobbying
for the job this way is it's very
unappealing I mean I'm already him but I
don't want to talk about it Michael
Knowles will be the sheriff of chicken
City you remind me of Michael Knowles
has anyone ever told you that before uh
no but I I know who he is he's a good
looking guy so I'll take it absolutely
all right
Gabby Hayes says Ian I want you to know
you have a true supporter in me everyone
else may not always know where you come
from but I know it's from a place of
love and passion glad you're back Long
Live Tim cast thanks Gabby
Daystar says who do you think supplied
those drones
um well if it was Russia then Russia if
it was Ukraine then yeah Iran Iran's
been supplying drones to the Russians to
the Russians yeah oh yeah but they're
like small ones aren't they
I I can't say I know the exact models
but
um
um you know that's where they've been
getting their drones from
Casey Willis says first Super Chat ever
and I've been listening since day one
had my first cup of your Appalachian
nights blend this morning and I do have
to say as a usual Drinker of Folgers
your coffee is chef's kiss oh yeah so
the two signature Blends we have now we
have a light and a dark and we have like
a very light and a very dark next we're
making is uh so this will be about six
weeks is a medium and two d a light and
a dark decaf so the medium roast is
stand your grounds and then we have
unwoke and sleepy Joe the decaf ones
those are those are those are great will
you bring uh rides with Roberto Jr
tomorrow yeah we'll try a little before
the show uh we need to order a bunch
more but uh Appalachian nights is is a
very very dark roast it's not as dark as
an espresso blend but it is that's less
less caffeine but maybe bring that one
do you have that one okay we did before
but we drank it all then the new orders
came in and I ordered just a single
sample for display and rise with Roberto
Jr if you like a Nutty blend I mean very
bright yeah it's it's really a lot of
fresh smell because Newsmax have its own
coffee they don't have their own coffee
but they're generous with coffees like
they have a machine where you know you
just push this button the thing comes
and then like they have like 15
different blends that you can choose
from which all look like the same
communist blend but uh and you stick it
up it's like a pouch right it's a pouch
and you stick it in there and it's got
the complete tip at the at the top of
the pouch and you close the thing and
coffee comes out and I drink it yeah
there you go it's free are you gonna do
K-Cups for yes those are currently in
production pickups so we're the first
thing we're gonna do is we're going to
order like a thousand for us here and
they're gonna be just like unlabeled
just so that we can have them so we can
drain them because I want to have my
coffee in the morning but uh K-Cups are
in production cool and we're we're uh I
was adamant that we we make
biodegradable yes thank you sir however
that is gonna probably be the next batch
after the first one because the they're
not quite at production capability yeah
cool but I'm really excited about that I
wouldn't want to do K-Cups if if the
future of it was just making more
plastic garbage yeah but and also I
don't like eating the plastic so you
know but the biodegradable ones are made
of like corn protein or something so
they break down all right Glenn 1833
says a focus microwave or EMP burst
defense gun yeah that's kind of what I
thought yeah um microwaves will scramble
the signal but people uh and if you can
heat it up you can knock it out of the
sky short it out so you need a lot of
power
uh scrambling the signal I mean to say
isn't enough because these things are
pre-programmed you don't it doesn't need
remote control it knows where it's going
Goldilocks production says Israel's Iron
Dome can take out hundreds of rockets at
one time if it can take out multiple
near supersonic rockets at one time with
an almost 97 accuracy rate it can handle
hundreds of drones I disagree we're
talking about small drones the size of
your fist carrying an explosive payload
and we're talking about thousands and
even hundreds they're going to be flying
low and over buildings they're not going
to be able to be shot of the sky they
might be flying straight down too but
they're not going to come from way up
high they're going to be on the ground
they're going to jump over walls and go
to their targets what do you think
I I I you know I'd be I'd be I don't
want to give your expertise yeah I think
I'd have more expertise on a the
incestuous chickens and uh your chicken
and some of the other exotic subjects
we've covered fair enough chickens are
good people you know they just uh they
do chicken stuff purple says God bless
everyone here we're all here because we
want to be better stay confident and
believe in yourself Hard Times won't
last forever evil is real but we don't
have to let it to into our body and mind
always remember Jesus loves you look I I
think the night is always darkest for
the dawn the bad things that are
happening are not the apocalypse humans
have faced great struggles and the
struggles make us stronger so if weak
men make hard times we are in those hard
times but never forget those hard times
will make strong men so after we pull
through this everything's gonna get a
whole lot better that's the uh the
fourth turning we're in the fourth
turning now the next season will be
spring and then we're gonna see 60 years
of prosperity and then 20 years of
Calamity but this is what I was asking
you earlier I was saying do you do you
regard that the American Enterprise is
forordained to success that that is that
will always elude the Chinese Enterprise
now you sound more optimistic but China
is going to go through a similar thing
right they they they their moral
bankruptcy will lead to it's it's as the
saying goes strong uh uh strong men make
good times good times make weak men weak
men make Hard Times Hard Times make
strong men it's everyone's going to go
through that so I think the planet will
just be changing I think the US is set
for a hard fall we'll probably lose
superpower status I can't see how we
maintain it with the Petro dollar
already how will we know when we have
lost superpower status what will be the
the when your laptop unstakable clue
you'll want to buy a laptop and it'll
cost you seven thousand dollars or I
think when American military bases start
getting taken over yeah in their in
their native countries and then
especially you know bad but I think the
first thing we'll start seeing is
Imports will become exorbitantly
expensive
because the Petro dollar will just be
weak and the US won't be exporting
anything and then it's going to become
harder to come by certain Goods we'll
start seeing serious inflation China
will move on Taiwan and we'll shrug
things like that will start happening
but uh grains of sand making a heat uh
you won't recognize the history until
the history is passed we could be in
World War III right now and we won't
know until 50 years afterwards when this
story and say well we believe it started
on this like well it's like a recession
yes right yeah you got to be in it
before you know you're in it
let's grab some more Super chats
dim sum nimsum says the Drone attack
seems as incompetent as the Ukrainian
attack with the fighter missile in 2014
maybe both were CIA yeah it just went
right down at the gentle angle right
into above the flag and then just blew
up right there
yeah that's what the Kremlin said they
took took it out right where they wanted
to take it out so they made it look like
it was attacking but it was just details
I have to say it's just such a cheap
attempt it looks so cheap staged yeah
OMG puppy says Russia has a system
called the Dead Hand that will
automatically launch a second strike
even if we vaporize Moscow and I I
believe that exists
um what I'm saying is that nuclear war
isn't the Apex when people talk about
nuclear war mutually charge destruction
what what people need to understand
about that is it's referring to the very
end of the nuclear war not the beginning
and middle of it
most people when I talked about
mutilation destruction they so this is
how it comes up I say you know I think
Putin will use nukes no he won't because
mutually sure destruction I'm like dude
the start of the war is not Putin being
like blow up New York and then we fire
back it's him being like tactical
Nuclear artillery wipe out Kiev and then
us being like
I don't want to sacrifice my capital for
Ukraine so what do we do let's send in
troops let's declare war but it's not
going to immediately be icbms flying all
over the place and to your point uh when
the Soviets installed uh nuclear
missiles on Cuba precipitating the Cuban
Missile Crisis people forget this they
also sent 40 000 Russian Personnel
Soviet Personnel to Cuba to to build
they had to build roads it was crazy but
the point being that as you say it's not
just there's a there's a missile flying
through the air and suddenly we're in
nuclear war the the machinations that
are necessary just to launch one nuclear
missile are fairly elaborate and
detectable so that we would have more
warning than just the the radar system
telling it doesn't suddenly happen that
the projectile is in the air Kalashnikov
says Tim you should make Matt Walsh
Watch Attack on Titan or Psychopaths
then see if he holds the same ignorant
opinions that all anime is demonic does
he really believe that I mean I don't
know my guess is that he likes to troll
mixed in with with his right he's being
he's being somewhat facetious when he
says it's all demonic he's just trying
to get a rise but he thinks a lot of it
is I do think there's a lot of really
bad anime but that's also like saying we
got bad cartoons in the United States
too also if he does and you don't agree
like that's fine isn't it nobody's wrong
okay he's not allowed to have bad
opinions that's true like most of his
opinions actually know better exactly I
went through Facebook Matt Walsh is
based therefore I am disappointed to
hear that he doesn't like it I went
through disagree with anyone he has to
have the correct opinion always I
thought that entertainment and alcohol
were like the devil were demon and but
then I realized I was extremely
egotistical in that time and that like a
balance of these things is part of the
nature yeah for sure
says sitting in the ER with an eye patch
on and I still wouldn't miss the show
even if I'm 20 minutes behind to keep up
the good works wow hope you're okay heal
up what if he's just hanging out there
though he's fine he just went to the ER
and hung up and work an eye patch
because it looks cool he's just living
his life
or maybe just after he hit send on that
message he was subjected to gross
medical malpractice and he's not even
with us anymore I hate to bring up those
kinds and where are the dark ones come
on sir it's the Grim cast David Toronto
says sorry I'm against all drag now look
what people accepting has led to it's
give an inch take a mile I'm done giving
nope well that's that's that's where
we're at hyperpolarization I'm gonna
wear a dress on the show just to do it
to you
I suppose the the challenge is you know
when Jordan Peterson talks about social
enforcement there was shared morality on
what the parameters were what what we
should and should not do and we got to
the point where liberals won Live and
Let Live anyone can do whatever they
want but if anyone can do whatever they
want you now have to explain to a child
why it is that someone is doing
something in public which leads to the
expansion of whatever these things are
and that's that's where we're at
Joe spinella said the Navy just asked
Bud Light to hold their beer quite
literally they were like hey you want
some Bud Light they're going to be the
new uh Bud Light partner the Navy it's
not going to get better
Rebecca carne is that it says Carn I did
five years as a corpsman in the Navy
this drag trans and other stuff makes me
glad I'm not in anymore also active duty
members can protest but not in uniform
or stake their active duty
interesting
I just don't understand why Bud Light
didn't make Dylan Mulvaney the face of
their Seltzer which they are constantly
trying to say like no one would have
cared no one would have cared this whole
thing would have been avoided and then
suddenly Bud Light Seltzer would have
had sort of this this brand era that
they're apparently trying to use to
connect with the youth so you know did
the marketing uh VP get her job back I
haven't been following she's still on
leave but I don't know if that means
she's coming back which I bet she is one
day
Kyle Miller says Tim as someone who
works in Disaster Recovery there is no
recovery plan for if a civil event was
to happen we would be stagnant for
decades a civil event like War in the
United States or something or like a
breakdown well we have a Presidential
Directive 51 which the president can
just create a new government and erase
the old one by signing a paper yeah good
luck with that President it and it will
happen maybe on the federal level but
states are like yeah no the blue States
would say Okay outright and then it'd be
really interesting after that probably
only Florida and South Dakota would say
no I could see it as like a defensive
maneuver but
you know I mean people people need to
read more about the Civil War because
they were slave states that were like we
disagree with what's going on but we
really don't want to go to war dude I
was just at Harpers Ferry yesterday or
two days ago my God that it was 180
years ago and they were just burning the
city to the ground
the story of Harper's Ferry the biggest
mistake John Brown made was he let the
train leave he's John Brown said slavery
is an act of War slavery slavery is an
act of War that's a quote from John
Brown yeah John Brown was Notorious for
just him and his kids going and killing
people
crazy guy and they claim he's a hero
I mean I at least assigned it in
Harper's Ferry and because of him we
have done the righteous thing and now we
have no slavery in the country I mean he
failed
like he he everything he did he tried
really hard so we should give him
something he did kill people but he took
the Armory and then failed and the
slaves that were here were like we don't
want to be involved in what you're doing
man and he was like oh and then they
came and they they hung him hanged him
sorry he hanged him
oh
legumeth again says Ian how can you be
so full of such illiterate Fury and
passion about things you barely
comprehend on even a semantic level I
beg you with tears in my eyes to never
describe yourself as becoming Jewish
ever again but it's true Shalom Aki oh
Shalom to you man no I'm not exerting no
no no I'm just getting in touch with god
without the middleman
okay
well all right
where are we at Dorian Marius Grace as
if Luke was there he would remind him
that no politician is coming to save you
why you are putting so much faith in
Trump as the savior of the world I'm not
I'm saying the only thing that has a
potential to actually Purge the
corruption in this in this government is
probably Trump but I didn't say I was
gonna save anybody I said it is going to
get worse we are going to fall off as a
global superpower whether Trump does
anything or not Trump will just kind of
bring back some some seed of
stabilization after he's gone
we'll see though man I don't know I'm
not psychic I'm not not like that
Nostradamus guy who just happened to
know everything right no you have
internet video so you're able to
convince people you don't just have to
just make petitions in your basement
Matt Walsh always has the right opinion
and you have to know everything ahead of
time I thought this was the agreement
you guys made with the internet in 2007
I was obsessed with ending the the
liberal economic order not ending it but
I was like oh this whole American
Military Base all of Earth is horrible
let's stop it and everyone agreed like
that knew about it but now we're
actually watching it happen and it's
like uh what's the alternative we got it
we got to import one here uh Michelle
Therese says Tim and crew great show and
great guest James check out the Genovese
documentary made by Kitty's brother
where he debunks the story that no one
came to Kitty's Aid people did call the
police and stayed with her while waiting
for the ambulance
that's not how it was taught but I will
check it out I wonder what uh platform I
can see that I don't trust the media so
I mean I hear that I'm like all right
you know I'll considered company
excluded of course
take it with a large Shaker of salt that
was what he said in response to the
Ukraine theoretical assassination
attempt just to make a point to uh 911
or 911 9-1-1 wasn't a thing in New York
up until four years after that they
actually used that case to make a point
for having 911 interest in the city so
just know Scary Terry says the Discord
should vote on the Roberto Jr successor
Roberto Jr is we're gonna build him like
something special do we have bionic
chicken yeah well I actually wanted a 3D
print chicken armor and one thing I
wanted to consider was can we put
together some kind of carbon fiber uh
Wing extensions to allow the chickens to
fly better
I think you can be done okay Arrow gel
graphene Arrow gel something threaded
it's strong enough uh it's super
lightweight if you do if you do an arrow
gel with carbon fiber strands going
through it to give it structural support
stability then it it probably would work
is the is the air but the Aero gel would
be brittle isn't it yeah but when it's
mixed with just other things you can
become very strong like there's a stuff
called air Loi it's a it's an arrow gel
compound that you can hit with a hammer
and machine it and stuff I want to do
like a helmet and body armor for the
chickens and one thing I really want to
make for uh bocus is imagine we gave him
a wing suit like a background so when he
jumps the wings deploy and he Glides and
when he lands they retract so long as
his feet are out the Wings come out you
can buy all of this stuff at acme.com
right it's just that they have bad
testimonials from one coyote who had
apparently bad experiences I just think
the world would be greatly improved if
we made wingsuits for cats I think it
could be interesting
read the successor question do the
candidates have to make promotional
videos that are then shared on Discord
you know that way you really get to know
them they can say what their policies
are what they would be in favor of we
might it might be one of the silkies
um because then we'll have soft fluffy
chickens I like that but um maybe a
little Luke because he's got a cool
haircut in my mind because the silkies
live in a coop inside the coop or at
least they did for so long they are more
scared so it's hard for me to imagine
one of them taking over this this job of
leading the chicken Army oh yeah and it
makes them more vulnerable to attack
right so if again hard to imagine them
being no The Roosters the rooster's fine
okay you can't have two roosters one
with the domed had one with not so
little Luke has a domed head so if he
gets pecked in the head he'll get a
concussion and die but uh if he's the
only rooster he's got nothing to worry
about
so but but little Luke's feet are also
like messed up so we're not even sure
he'll be able to properly you know
it's like the the uh the crippled son of
some sort of Monarch who's like got this
channel sure yeah like you've got a
chance I've never seen Game of Thrones
we wanted to do uh Sarah's son
um Isaac but he's too big because he's a
Brahma and so
he's gonna hurt the the ladies he's just
he's massive so do you guys think that
people consider installing politicians
this in such detail as we do with the
chicken his domed head makes him
vulnerable
I don't know about Biden his Dome Ted
all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash the like
button subscribe to this channel share
this show with your friends and become a
member by going to timcast.com and
clicking join us where you can hang out
in the Discord server with like-minded
individuals submit questions and even
call in to our members only after show
which will be live in about 10 minutes
on the front page of timcast.com this
one is uh once again probably not so
family friendly so you don't want to
miss it again timcast.com you can follow
the show at timcastirl you can follow me
personally at timcast and guess what Tim
cast news on Twitter has now a gold
verification badge which is very good
news and then the people who work at Tim
casca a little Tim cast thing next to
their name because Twitter is doing good
stuff so uh yeah do that and uh James
you want to shout anything out just it
was great to be with you all once again
I'm James Rosen I cover the white house
for Newsmax you can see my work on
Newsmax you can follow me on Twitter at
James Rosen TV and I am the author of a
new book Scalia rise to Greatness
1936-1986 first volume of a two-volume
biography of someone who is really one
of the most important Americans of the
last hundred years Antonin Scalia and
it's out now it is cool I'm here sorry I
got a question for you right when we
start the members only show that
everybody wants to hear but uh we'll
we'll okay we'll save it okay about
Scalia I'm Hannah Claire brimlow I'm a
writer for timcast.com I am very newly
verified on Twitter so if you want to
follow me there I'm at HC brimlow I'm
Hannah claire.b on Instagram and more
importantly you should follow at timcast
news on Twitter and Instagram you can
read stuff from me from Chris Bartman
from Adrian Norman all of our
journalists there it's really uh to me
the best part of the website and yeah
thanks so much for uh tuning in tonight
thank you Hannah Claire I'm Ian
Crossland you guys can follow me Ian
crossland.net subscribe to me on YouTube
at Ian Crossland Twitter follow me there
at Ian Crossland James what a night
raucous quite an event and tell me again
you've told me before before the record
your favorite Beatles album
this is this is so dirty on your part
you know that I that I reject the any
true Beatles freak rejects the whole
who's your favorite Beetle favorite
Beatle song favorite Beetle album Now
John I do you're right just be just come
on just come out I do have a favorite
solo Beetle that's permissible okay but
not a favorite thing well let's let's
surge it was a utilitarian response The
White Album it's the longest album I'm
not going to be forced to choose if
forced to choose one chooses The White
Album it's a lot it's good the only
Double Apple good meat people should
come surge is also here pressing mine's
revolver he's just watching what's up
guys it's serve.com uh ready for the
after show let's go all right everybody
we'll see you all over at timcast.com in
about 10 minutes thanks for hanging out